[音楽]
ブードゥー君
まず最初に
私が二十歳の時に経験したことを皆さんにも感じてほしいなと思います
二十歳私は大学3年生でした
皆さんは何をしていますか
推進してきました
あいきましたありがとうございますはい
健康診断このまいりましたねー
その健康診断で
医者に
あなたはこう言われます
[音楽]
ちょっと気になる点がありますね
明日
大学病院に行ってもらえますか
私の方で予約を取っていました
いいですか明日
ならず大学病院行くんですよ
いきなり明日ですよ
そう言われてもと思いつつその意志の気迫に押され
あなたはした大学病院に行きます
そこではさまざまな検査が待っていました
その検査の後
大学病院の java こう言います
[音楽]
ちょっとやっかいな病気ですね
早めの治療した方がいいと思います
3ヶ月
その程度でしょうかやされますか
おとといまでは何でもなかったあなたは
生きたり4日ナビ理由だそうです
厄介な病気ん
何ですか
ハタチのあなたは
ガーになりました
私のプロフィールを少し紹介しましょう
今のように私は二十歳の時に元になりました
そもそも
私は
に布石水という障害を持って生まれてきた人間です
歩い方がおかしいそして杖をついている
体が小さいこれはから2分脊髄という病気によるもので
二十歳で清掃官の知郎してプリン興味を持った私は大学卒業後
製薬企業に入ります
そして
その企業を辞めた後ページェントサロン協会という会を立ち上げ
存在表示しています
それとは別に年前に今度は甲状腺がになりました
こちらのがんは治ることはありません
一生元と付き合っていく
そういう人生を余儀なくされたり音です
日頃は
主役企業や大学などで研修や講演活動をしています
今日は患者と医療者の心の距離を近づけるという
これからの医療の在り方についてお話をしたいと思います
がんの治療している私は医療の現場で
いろんなことを想いそして考えました
高く3年生三角つ休んだ留年しちゃうじゃないですか
大学に早く深くしたいんだけど
いたいなぁと思います
言えませんでした
a 髪の毛抜けちゃうんですか
いきたいなと思いましたが聞けませんでしたん
医療費どんぐらいかかるんだろう
いう知りたいなぁと思ったことすら知れませんでした
当時付き合ってた彼女がいますが彼女にどう説明すればいいんだ
相談したいなと思いましたけどスボタンできませんでした
医療の現場って
患者の立場で入ると言いたいことを伝えこと
口に出せないなぁ
でもそれって全部自分のことですよね
あなたは病院に行った時そういうこと思った時ありませんか
といいな
そんな気がするんです
製薬企業に入った私はいろんなことを学びました
そのなかの1つに患者中心の医療という考え方があります
医者や看護師や薬剤師
あるいは製薬企業の含むも含めいろんな職種の方が連携をしてチームになって患者さん
のために頑張りましょう
でも
この
絵を見て
言葉を聞いて
違和感はないですか
もっともっと
身近な例を考えてみたいと思います
皆さんにお尋ねしますこの中で花粉症のしております
彼もシャワーいます悪くつこ言いますねありがとうございます
花粉症の人どうでしょう
アレルギーの症状でくしゃみや鼻水が出たら病院に行って
そうすると医者がうーんあなた花粉症ですねじゃあ薬出しておきましょう
満足ですか
そもそもま花粉症はあまり治せない病気かなと思いますけれど
その病気の付き合い方ってさまざまあると思うんです
例えば
今週末屋外で彼女と初めてのデートです
今週末なんとかくしゃみと花火務められませんか
っていう方もいるでしょ
いやいやいもう今集合と忙しく打って24時間やっているドラッグストアーてお薬で
なんとかしたいんです
技術の昼間しか言ってない
この病院にはなかなか来れないんですよ
いい薬を紹介してくださいって言うか違っているでしょ
いやもうあエネルギーつらくって何年かかってもいいから
た椅子を改善したいんです
そういう形だっているでしょ
要はあなたはどういう医療を受けたいんでしょ
あなた自身がそれを考えて
それを口にしなかったろう
医療というのは本来始まらないものなんです
いやこれはね
医療だけの話じゃないんですよ
そもそもとしてあなたはどういう生活を送りたいと思っていますか
そこにつながる話なんです
あなたは今
どういう生活を送りたいか
聞かれて
きちんと言葉に出来ますか
ハタチの私にはそれができませんでした
先ほど私は患者中心の医療とこのよう見せまして違和感があると言いましたけれど
本来
あなたも医療者と同じはの中に入る
あなたがどういう医療を受けたいのか
それを医療したという
そこから医療というのは始まるはずなんです
これを私は患者中心じゃ楽
患者共同の威力という風に言っています
患者共同の医療において必要なことそれは何かといったら
対等の立場医療者と患者は対等な立場でありそこに本音の対話があるということです
この対等な対話というのは
医療者の意識を変える可能性があります
今まではあなたの症状にしか興味がなく
病名をつけるそれがいローラーと思っていただけましたんだけれどもあなたが根底に
考えるそもそも同医療を受け
どんな生活をしたいのか
この情報を医療者がいることによってあなたに寄り添った医療提供できる可能性がある
のです
それにより今まで遠いなあと思ったよ
少し近くの医療になる
a を挙げてみましょう
元ロクセリ抗がん剤といいますが
抗がん剤を打った私は一晩にして髪の毛かすべて受けました
かわいい
出生
いいですよ
1番手
今あるこの髪の毛がコーナーなんです
あなたが今この髪型になったらどういう気持ちになりますか
今日ここに来れますか
電車の中のほかの人の目が痛いとなりん座っているお友達に
なんていうを
そういう気持ちになり外に出れないかも知れませ
そうなんです
この髪の毛が抜けるこれが辛いんじゃないんですよ
髪の毛が抜けることによって周りの人との関係性が崩れていく変わっていくこれが強い
んです
もし両者にそこまで言うことができたら
この移動車どういうふうに対応するでしょ
今は担任この薬打ったらあなたの髪の毛抜けますよという話です
だけれどもあなたが周りの人との関係性が壊れるのが使う
その気持ちを言ったら
では
この髪の毛が抜けた後に薄く使えるように
ウィックカツラですじゃあウィッグを用意しておきましょうか
頭のサイズを測るんですよく作る時
だけど今髪の毛があるだから1センチヒールで小さなサイズにしてください
そんな話が出ます
医療じゃないですよね
だけれども患者に寄り添った医療というのはそういうことじゃないでしょうか
このように
患者さんや医療者が対等に対話する場がもっともっと普通に欲しいなと思いました
私は医療者ではありませんので民間のこういうカフェ丘で切って活動を始めました
月に1回ページェントサロン預けて活動したんです
ここにはその時の1前写真を持ってきました
ここに医者がいて薬剤師がい理学療法士という医療者がいて
看護の学生がいてそして患者がいます
一つテーブルを囲んでみんなが本音の対話をしています
毎回テーマを決めています例えば
医者と思いを共有するにはどうしたらいいんだろう
どうやって病院を選んだらいいんだろう
毎回毎回いろいろなテーマを置いて対バンするんです
立場が違う人から経験意見知識
アイディアがあったされます
お互いにお互いが気付きや学びあそういう場です
今月で80回迎えました回収して810か月ということです
いろんな感想や意見が聞かれます
医療者の側からは
感謝さんの疾患だけじゃなくってもっともっと重いよ
聞きたくなりました
診察して治療法を一方的に言ってたかもしれないけれど
患者さんの生活を考えた治療法
一緒に考えます
もっともっと患者さんの生活
そして医療への思いを聞くっていいなと
こんな声が寄せられます
患者の側からも様々声があります
そっか自分の想いを審査し州で語っていいんですね
そしてそれが大切なんですね
そんな感想もあります
普段どんなが生活
期待しているのか望んでいるのか
そんなことを考えたときはなかっただけれどもそういうふうな
大切なんですね
この場で考えさせられました
とにさまざまな意見が寄せられます
こうやって
活動を回を重ねていくと
私もやりたい
一緒にやりませんか
そういう人が何も現れて
ページェントサロンという勝つと私がいつも借りているカフェだけじゃなくて皆さんの
地元でもやるようにしよう
そういう風になって組織化したのがピーシャインスターロン教会です
今私はこの会代表しているわけです
ここではページェントサロンの具体的な手法を学んでいただいてそれをご自身の
ページェント去ろうとして
自宅の近くで介在していただく
そういう活動をしています
といいつつまだ全国でたった8か所しかありません
もっともっと各地に広げていきたいなぁ
希望を待っています
あいにくこの頭でもまだ開催されていません
5日この地でもページェント佐野ができたら嬉しいなぁと思ってい
このように
患者強度はないよそして対等な台湾すればそれが全国に広がったらきっと今まで
医療が遠いなぁ感じたその気持ちも
少し
近づくんではないでしょう
でもねぇ
そういうのって文化を変えるということです
なかなかすぐにできるものではありません
ですから今日ここにいる皆さん
お願いがあるんです
まずは
あなた自身が
どういう生活を送りたいと考えていたのか
それを考えそして口にできるようになっていただきたいんです
そして
私のように元になったりあるいは治りにくい
花粉症になったり
そうなったら
あなたがどういう医療を受けたいのか
勇気を出してい業者に伝えてほしいんです
医療者はあなたのその一言
待っているんですよ
今健康な時だからこそ
考えていただきたいんです
その言葉を医療者に伝える
その一言か
患者と医療者の心の距離を近づけると
これからの医療のあり方ではないでしょうか
どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]